das ist ja ganz klar wie sehr dieser
besuch von seiner symbolik er die markus
söder heute hilft aber was bringt ja
eigentlich der kanzlerin also was hat
die für nutzen von diesem besuch heute
ich denke dass die ganze natürlich auch
genau weiß wie sich die
beliebtheitswerte von markus söder
entwickelt haben
auf der anderen seite ist es ja nicht so
dass dieser besuch ganz kurzfristig
geplant wurde sogar das wird ja monate
zuvor ich nehme an schon sogar vor der
korona zeit am ende eingestellt worden
seien ja die eu ratspräsidentschaft
all diese dinge sind klar ich glaube
natürlich gefällt der kanzlerin dass sie
als diejenige die von der csu
am ende ja symbolisch zumindest
ausgebuht wurde auf dem parteitag wir
erinnern uns alle an dieses bild von
horst seehofer der die kanzlerin da
neben sich hatte wie ein schulmädchen
sie behandelt hat wie eine ein bisschen
ausgestoßene wir erinnern uns an die
frage der debatte ob cdu/csu sich am
ende sogar entzweien könnten also
natürlich gefällt der kanzlerin das ist
scheinbar am ende so ist das auch die
csu wieder um 7
sie hat natürlich in den umfragewerten
während der korona krise noch mehr
profitiert als markus söder also noch
steht sie zumindest in wenigen prozenten
vor ihm und es ist jetzt so und auch das
gehört ja zur wahrheit dazu dass sich
wenn man das ganze politisch betrachtet
oder politisch analysiert markus söder
sich eher auf sie zubewegt hat nämlich
von der harten haltung in der asylfrage
in der flüchtlingsfrage wo er über asyl
tourismus gewettert hatte wirklich ja
wie versucht hat darf die wieder
zurückzubekommen sich dann eher in ihre
in ihre richtung in der staatsmännische
entwickelt hat und auch in einer
situation wo er zumindest versucht
aufbricht in richtung der grünen
zuzugehen es gab ein sehr spannendes
gespräch mit markus blume vor wenigen
wochen in der zeit wo er klar gemacht
hat dass das aus seiner sicht oder aus
csu sicht eben ein fehler war damals
dass sie einen fehler gemacht haben dass
sie zu sehr richtung in die andere
richtung blickt haben dass das die
wähler eben nicht goutiert haben und
dass sie sozusagen jetzt eine ganz
andere politik fahren wo sie plötzlich
auch attraktiv für grünen wähler für spd
wähler sind